today we have the opportunity to explore
the wonderful world of micro electronics
and we've got a great guide we have
professor Eugenio Carla cello he's a
professor of electrical engineering here
at Yale and he's gonna tell you about
some of his research in micro
electronics he's doing some really neat
things so we'll welcome him to the
podium and thank you everyone as well
good morning everyone can you all hear
me and I'm sorry about my accent I hope
you can get through that too as well by
the way if you if you don't understand
anything just to stop me let me know if
you have any question even during the
talk just just ask I'll try to answer if
I know the answer so today I wanted to
tell you a little bit about what the
microelectronic world and also what do
we do during everyday as electrical
engineer a little bit of you know the
real job and also in recent and I think
you're all very familiar with
electronics you know I think the
electronics have changed the way we live
lives and you all know this because you
all have some of these gadgets let me
let me do a little survey here how many
of you have a computer nice who doesn't
have a computer I'll buy you one
just kidding
how many how many of you have a cell
phone
mum and dad didn't buy you one yes sir
Wow bad luck so welcome welcome you guys
to saying Saturday
what good
okay everybody found the seat okay I'll
proceed some electronics change your
life but many of you might not be aware
of it I think because you know maybe you
haven't seen how things changed and now
I start to sound like my grandfather but
I wanted to tell you a little bit of
what I mean okay so a lot of things that
you guys use every day like a computer
or a cell phone I've only been here very
few you know 20 30 years very little
time and and they really change our
lives I'll try to I'll try to tell you
why first and then we'll we'll go and
see how these things are made so first
of all if we wanted to communicate
between you know one person another
person 100 years ago we didn't have all
these gadgets and toys what did we have
what did we use oh yeah I don't know
those about voice okay well yeah Morse
code to megaphone yes yes I have a
picture of those right there right so we
had to use our voice maybe a megaphone
or I don't know how else it's called in
English okay or maybe one of these
gadgets one of these toys if you want to
communicate long distance right and if
you wanted to talk to a lot of people
well you had to you know to group them
all together someplace in a room like in
a town meeting and talk to them but you
couldn't talk to more than 100 people
directly you know 100,000 people that
were that to be another person had to to
repeat what I was saying to other a
hundred people and so forth to spread
out like that it was a long process and
if you wanted to communicate between one
city to another city then you have to
use beacon so how many of you guys saw
the Lord of the Rings the movie right so
you remember that they were using
because to communicate when they were
getting all these people for the final
battle right they're using the speaker
so they were like fires and they will
say Carmel you know so those are the way
it was pretty rude but that's the way
you
to communicate but then you know just in
the last hundred hundred years basically
thanks to the electronic Abel evolution
or revolution are you going to call it
then we started having gadgets like this
so on the top it's my grandma's phone
maybe some of you guys have seen it
before in the middle there's the phone
that you know when I was born and that's
what we have today
okay the telephone so this is a nice toy
and today all of us have a cell phone
you know like this or in many other
incarnations right so this is the
evolution but you know this is very
recent this is just the 10-15 years ago
okay that everybody could buy one of
these so what can we equate why did life
change with these gadgets you know
because before you could only talk to a
few people around you like I'm talking
to you right now actually you know I'm
held by electronic devices here still
there amplified my voice otherwise some
of you on the back might not hear me
unless I start talking really like like
a dinosaur and when the phone came out
then all of a sudden you could talk to
everywhere in the planet but you
couldn't really talk to a person you had
to talk to a house because you know the
house was hosting the phone the phone
was in the house so if I was if I was
looking for you for example I had to
call your house and if you were out
playing I couldn't find you and vice
versa you know you couldn't find me but
you know nowadays we have this we have
this gadget a cell phone and now I can
finally talk to anywhere on the planet
to a specific person and I can find them
wherever they are if they want to be
found
okay obviously this is a this is a good
revolution and evolution because it
allows us to talk to people we want but
also has some problems you know some of
which your parents are not too happy
about you know the problem with cell
phones but I'll try to keep on the
positive side here today so I'll just
tell you the good things
how's another thing that electronics
change in in my point of view another
reason why electronics really changed
our life is in the way we deal with
knowledge so how do we transfer
knowledge you know in the old times when
people would pass away they had no way
of living and in knowledge they
accumulated besides telling stories
maybe with stories they were passed
again by boys
or maybe you know like this is
prehistoric drawing in a cave they would
transfer some knowledge about I don't
know what kind of knowledge they would
transfer here but by drawing basically
you know so there was an evolution there
too in the lasted thousands of years but
it's nothing compared what electronics
has done in that in the last hundreds of
year of course there was the invention
of paper so finally people didn't have
to rely on boys to communicate if I
found something during my life I didn't
have to tell a story to somebody else I
could just write it so not one person
but many people could read it they
couldn't read exactly what I wanted to
say and then came the movable-type you
with the milk middle ages right and so
all of a sudden you could start writing
books yes it's probably English or Latin
or German somebody tells me German okay
so with the movable-type you could start
producing books although you didn't
really need movable-type to do books
they were books even before but with
movable type you could do many books can
print them in serious a lot of them okay
so this this was sort of the state of
the art until a hundred years ago right
and one thing that you have to remember
is nowadays is not so clear so if if
just not even a hundred years ago but
thirty years ago if I if I wanted to
find out something about knowledge human
knowledge if I wanted to find out how
many people are in Pakistan or was the
capital of Pakistan well then you know
maybe if I was lucky enough to have an
cyclopædia at home and not so many
people had that and I could read you
know maybe a few lines but if I wanted
to know more about Pakistan you know the
culture I had to go to the town library
so I had to make a trade you know half
an hour and support would take me some
effort to do this right but then you
know nowadays we have the internet all
of you all of you have it at your
disposal now you think oh you know it's
always been there it's no big deal but
it it is a big deal
you know and on the internet you can do
lots of things like pretending to be
someone else but I'm not teaching you
these tricks today this is what we see
every day right
no we wake up many of you maybe your
parents don't let you do that because
it's too much browsing you know but we
might Jobs I have to see this thing so
every day and then you know all of a
sudden I have the entire human knowledge
not in books but but over here so I
cannot just open my laptop I can search
for anything I don't have to go to the
town library I don't have to make a
special play by the way the town library
was just a small example but if I had
some crazy thing that I was studying you
know like culture of a special book in
Pakistan I would actually have to go to
Pakistan to find this book nowadays I
don't even have to do that it's most
probably in there so this is really neat
it's like the really great technology to
do these things but it gets even better
you know nowadays with this thing you
know because of some people I actually
have the internet in my hands so I don't
even have to go at home on my computers
but I can just look things up here like
we do it all the time you know what I'm
out with my wife I want to find out
where a movie is playing or she asked me
a question how many people in Pakistan I
don't know why I would want to know
and I find out you know because I'm you
know I'm a geek I want to know this and
it's really nice that you can find out
right away because you know when I was a
kid like you guys I couldn't find these
things out somebody would ask a question
we will all scratch our heads and say oh
my god you know and then we forget so
nobody would learn anything really but
now you can so this is a big big
revolution you know and many of you
might not be aware that it's only like
20 or 30 years old really okay but so
first I wanted to start with the some
history but you know that's not why
you're here today today you're here
because you wanted to know what's what's
inside my gameboy
ABS PlayStation 3 Xbox how many have RDS
how many places should bring me two how
many good how many are we it's fun right
okay whatever you have the wrong fan I
think they're all really great toys but
you know they actually use the same
devices that are used in a computer in a
cell phone nowadays to do different kind
of tasks you know something now that you
can play games with them and I'll show
you so all of these things you know both
the internet now even cell phones are
really computers you know the new cell
phones that you buy they're little tiny
computer if you buy a new one so all of
this is because all of this revolution
most of it happened with the computer
nowadays that's the way we communicate I
talk to my man with Skype on the
computer you know I see her so I can not
only compute find information but also
communicate right and this is all all
computers are made with very simple
elements they're made with a switch like
a light switch how many of you have seen
a light switch or have one in their home
all of you right who doesn't have one
come on you have one you see okay so but
that's that's a pretty big switch but
you know then scientists started to
scratch their heads and they wanted to
miniaturize this and they made this
thing in the middle which looks really
ugly in reality is really tiny it was
just somebody a bells lab in the fifties
then made that and then you know in the
70s they made this which is really tiny
it's like the earth you pinky little
nail
it's a tiny instead and now transistors
in in the device that I'm going to show
you they're they're so tiny that we
don't see them like if you take one of
your hair I can put thousands of them in
inside one of your hair
millions of them they became really
really tiny
yeah even your ears yes so how many of
you flip the switch in your house
recently today okay I think if you can
do that then you can design computers so
after after this we can all meet down
there with design and you computer
together if you want so computer I'm
going to teach you you know if you want
to learn something today just to stay
awake the next two minutes that's what I
wanted to teach you a computer is made
of a lot of switches and switches are
like the one that you switch to turn on
or off alike okay so very very simple
things but it just gets a little bit
more complicated so if I put two
switches you know one in series with the
other so I have two switches okay in
order for me to turn on the light I have
to make this this line here continues I
have to make it go from this node to
this node so I have to flick switch one
and I have to sweep
flicks switch to right both of them if I
do only one is not going to turn on the
light so that's one of the logic
function in a computer that's deadly
and function okay it's one of the
function we need three functions and
then we can make any computers we want
it's really simple so one of them is
this say if the two switches I have to
flick both of them they flick only one
doesn't work the light doesn't turn on
then there's a nut switch which is kind
of a funny thing because the light is
always on and I flick the switch when
I'd want to turn it off okay so it's
like an invert that kind of thing like a
security like that it's always on but I
only only want to turn it off sometimes
that's a not not logic function and then
there's the or logic function and now
look look at this you know this I have
two parallel wires here with two
switches they're in parallel so now if I
want to turn on this light I don't have
to flick both switches I just need to
flick one either the top one or the
bottom one and the light will turn on
let's the or gate either one or the
other so now with these three functions
the end not and/or we can make any
computers including your Gameboy PS
myself on and so forth isn't it cool
isn't it simple enough yes the
touchscreen oh that's a difficult
question Allah allows you to data in a
few minutes okay but so okay now you see
all this little of this little end gate
or gate
we call them gates they have a symbol
like that can you recognize it it's like
a little half circle this is the end and
gate here this is the symbol for the
knob we give them a simple just to
remember them like a picture you know
it's it's easier otherwise we would
forget this is a or so it has this
little Halfmoon and then it's like a
gothic window no
so can you recognize them now
and not or so if I put 20 together 20
transistors so these things are made of
switches they have switches inside
called transistors and there's 20 of
them and I make this circuit soft so you
can find out here you know this is this
is the not right what is this one great
in this profit oh sorry oh you already
know how to design computers now I'm
gonna I'm gonna call you in my lab to do
some work so with 20 transistors you can
do this little circuit here which is
probably what controls your microwave
oven when you want to control the time
something like this you know something
simple or like a coke distributing
machine if you put 2000 transistor and
it gets complicated enough so here I'm
showing a drawing and inside here
there's all these little switches you
see of tiny they have so this picture is
magnified in reality this thing is like
you know your your thumb nail basically
and magnifying all of them so this is
the Intel who knows who it what Intel is
in don't they make microprocessor they
make this you know the basic element of
your computer what makes everything
brand programs and so forth so they were
one of the first to make microprocessor
in 71 that's the day before the year
before I was born they made this thing
2000 transistor okay and there's a
professor here called tippy MA
that lent me all these beautiful
pictures for some of them so then you go
to 74 few years later you go to 6,000
transistor now you don't see them
anymore they're so tiny they're you know
these little switches they become tiny
it looks Oh cram product it's hard to
see right and then you go to 1982 how
many years ago 1982
the vending here just so it's not that
long ago right not that long ago
thirteen thirteen hundred one hundred
thirty thousand transistors okay then
eighty five two hundred and seventy five
thousand transistors so now we don't see
them anymore at all
you know this which they become like you
crazy crazy features yes I'm sorry I'm
ignoring it yeah oh yeah exactly I'm
going to tell you in a second you're
asking me all this first well so they
they actually make I'm going to show you
in a couple of slides I have I have it
here because I knew that you were gonna
ask me this and then you know in 89 1
million how many is 1 million it's a lot
of how many people in New Haven you're
good
and which city has a million people here
in maybe the whole Connecticut
okay maybe the whole Connecticut maybe I
should look it up on the web but so
there's more transitional here switches
then people in New Haven or in the in
the area around you have so it's a lot
of a lot of little switches okay not the
big one that tiny one then we go to 93
we go to 3 million transistor 97 how
many years ago 97 well 7 million
transistors 99 28 million okay you get
the idea
mm 42 million this is now now that's
pretty much that's what I have in my
computer here the one that is projecting
things for you
410 million that's more than the people
that are in United States I'm not
mistaking okay a lot of these little
switches don't see them anymore here but
it gets better you know last year there
there were some some some new chips and
that have 2 billion transistors that's
like a third of the world's population
now a lot of them not lots and lots of
this is actually many things together so
how did they put all these things
together in here you know how is it
possible you know some of you asked me
how do I put all these switches in such
a tiny space yes your
the last picture yeah these are all you
know like basically your your thumb nail
that's the size I cannot hear you very
well
yes yeah
yes you're correct exactly so in order
to fit them because all of these
pictures that I showed you are about the
size of my nail so in order to put more
transistor there to make a smaller and
smaller and smaller okay so all these
engineers before me smarter than me they
did this you know they put all these
trances they made them smaller and
smaller and smaller okay in it and
that's like 30 years of work because the
first one was in 71 right so how do we
do this actually it's very simple you
know how many of you can draw on a piece
of paper more more come on all of you
can draw I don't see enough sign that I
didn't say beautiful drawing just any
draw and now how many of you draw
something with a computer good good so
if you draw something with a computer
you can really help me to make a
microprocessor a computer later it's
because all we do is we withdraw
withdraw shapes like this so this is you
know this shape here is a not one of
these gates that I showed you the end
now or not we draw them like this and
then we somebody with a big factory that
cost millions of millions of dollars
they make them really tiny
they have sophisticated machines they
make them really tiny and the way they
do this is they you know when you go to
a movie theater they project like now
there's a project or the project things
big instead of projecting things big
this machine project really small so
they make you know my transistor really
really tiny like a few nanometers like
million times smaller than your hair so
that's how these things are made and
this is the program this is the drawing
program that we use in my lab upstairs
so maybe not me but a lot of my students
they spend days drawing here
these are very simple drawing squares
really know that they're not a
complicated so you can draw this thing
you draw a gate
you draw 20 of these you made the first
circuit and if you replicate these 20
hundred times then you get to a thousand
you make a microprocessor that's how we
make them it's not so complicated really
this is this is for example a bigger
drawing that you know that I made a few
years ago this is an amplifier the one
that amplifies my voice here so you can
see how we drew every little thing with
a computer just drawing rectangles okay
well you know I told you all this boring
stuff but you really came here to see
what's in your Gameboy in and yes but
actually that's what's in your Gameboy
in the or das on your PSP a spring
there's all these chips or this tiny
little thing so I took a picture here
from the web of a Nintendo DS okay
actually the gameboy advance or intended
yes so here you see if you open up the
beautiful case you see all these
components right if I open up this case
here and this black thing
the biggest component that's the
microprocessor so that's basically one
of this okay one of these is inside here
this guy this black thing and it's it's
again you know slightly bigger than my
fingernail this is the Xbox how many of
you have an Xbox good good job
so you know this is this the
microprocessor it's here you see it's
tiny this is just a package he has a lot
of pins here has a thousand thousand of
connections but the circuit inside is
smaller it's like it's really like my
fingernail it's inside here that's
what's in there and this is the
PlayStation 3 who has a PlayStation 3 I
have one too I play with my wife
sometimes it's fun so this is this one
here is the self Cell processor so it's
a processor getting inside as 9
processor so it's like 9 computers why
because it has to do lots of beautiful
graphics but that's what's inside
nothing else so if you can build this
you can build the entire thing so here
is the the processor that is inside you
know if you have who has at home another
laptop a big computer with a big case ok
yeah so if you if you get a graphic card
to play video games with that computer
you buy a Geforce this is the the die
give a question yeah
oh this is you know all the stuff what I
could find
I found these pictures on the web no and
this is oh this is the chip of the Xbox
the new one this is the microchip so he
has actually free free microprocessor
inside one two and three and this is the
self process of the one in PlayStation 3
you see that as one two three four eight
eight little finger here there pieces
repeated there eight microprocessor
repeated to do give more beautiful
graphics okay in fact when I was a kid
you know maybe younger than you I had I
was playing with the Commodore 64 was
one small computer and we have games
like this you know the chicken wire
wireframe games the vector games and I
really loved them because you know all
of this even though they were really
ugly you know they're really ugly but I
loved that because they were made of
vectors and the computer was calculating
the image by computing it at every
instant so every time I would move it
would compute the new perspective and I
thought it was really cool so I told a
friend of mine that really loved soccer
it was playing soccer you know with
these things that you these games that
you look from the top and you have this
price this graphics moving around it's
like the old style and I told him he was
making fun of me because I was playing
this game he said ah you play this ugly
chicken-wire game you know what is that
I said you know one day they will make
your soccer with the chicken wire it
will look it will look beautiful he
didn't believe me and I got lucky in my
prediction because that's what happened
so nowadays we have this you know
PlayStation 3 can do this kind of stuff
and it's just a big fat microprocessor
with many units that can do a lot of
number crunching and they compute every
one of this is like a little polygon a
little triangle that it's you know as a
different color and there's so many of
them there's me
and millions they looks real and when
they move in real time the computer
calculates exactly how these things move
and changes and all the perspective all
the shadow it's a lot of calculations no
it's a lot of difficult problem but I
mean it looks beautiful right who
doesn't like it
why now come on ok parents don't like
video games right and it's you know it's
true you shouldn't waste all your day
playing video games but somehow some
video games is good you know they make
you faster they make you think faster
react I think some video game you know
like half an hour a day is good ok now I
got in trouble I'm gonna run away from
the back door here sleep ok last thing I
want to tell you now then then you can
go home is what what we do here in ATL
in my lab and other colleagues lab is we
use this microchip to do other things
not just computers but we use them for
example in medicine you know there are
microchips not not specifically us but
these are other example you know
microchips that can make you here better
if you have a hearing loss like you know
my grandfather or somebody that has a
problem or the space maker
if your heart is not able to pump
regularly and so forth yes given you
have another question scream ok can ask
me soon and in our lab we do similar
similar chips you know here for example
is one example here in is we make a
microchip that studies the brain so it
looks at how the brain is responding to
stimuli for example in animals so we
make a really tiny chip miniaturized you
know small again is much smaller than my
finger then we that make other
microchips to study cells to you know to
be able to develop new drugs there are
more safe to the consumer
also chips are used in robotics you know
because one one big thing one big market
of microchips these computers but
actually you know we really would like
to have robots doing you know washing
dishes right right or driving our car
now what else
Rowntree guess you know all these daily
tasks yes sir you've got another
question the vacuum vacuum cleaner yeah
yeah the race one the vacuum clean my
room bar there is a little robot but
that you know so that even that robot
there so that's what we have at home the
Roomba it cleans it's like a little
vacuum cleaner that's the state of the
art well it's actually pretty bad
because it doesn't do anything it's just
bumping around randomly really picking
up things I would actually like my robot
to do more interesting things you know I
go fetch my keys find that where I live
left my wallet you know things like this
but they can't do that you know and so
so in my in my lab we they can't do that
mostly because they robots cannot see
very well you don't have a very good
vision so in my lab we try to make
artificial eyes for robots I call them
the Terminator right which you know
allow robots to to see and find out for
example you know robot has a promise
they're telling go fetch my kids you
cannot find it and we can find it right
like that you know if I see him unless
you know somebody hidden under the table
or something but the robots even if it's
like in plain view you cannot see it
many times yes
Oh finally my kids know but I'm trying
really hard now actually I had some
success I didn't try with the keys with
other objects yeah we can we can do some
of this stuff but you know we were
getting there
and so this is a movie of one of the
same so that we made recently for
example you know I'll try to first
forward it a bit
this sensor can see different different
ways that you see you usually see
something rotating like this this sensor
instead only sees a different image just
the contour and only things that move
because these are the important
information in an image that then a
robot can process to find objects so
that's what we do in the lab more or
less ok and then we have applications
you know we do software that is able to
find objects for example this was made
on a on an iPhone in here for example
you show a pin and it's supposed to tell
you that this is a pin so it tells you
for example the first of the disappear
sometimes it messes up it's not right
and we try to do algorithm that sort of
mimic the way vision works for us ok so
those are things that we're doing in the
lab and I bite all of you to visit it
next time you're around and that's it I
wanted to conclude maybe I'll show you a
couple of things before before we go I
put up a page with all the people that
I've worked here in the last five six
years and most of the stuff that you see
that is done in my lab has been done by
a few people in the meantime I wanted to
show you just briefly before you go a
couple of these things
so this one here is you can see it is a
wafer okay so it's a very thin slice
where all these microchips are made it's
a thin slice of glass and all the
microchips are basically all the little
wires and little transistor are drawn in
here this is one of them which is really
nice because it shows you really what's
inside so you see all these big squares
it's a it's a little bit hard to see but
you see that there's like this the
pattern there's a little square
replicated and you can come here and
I'll show you so those are the micro
processors okay then people take this
this is what goes in the fabrication
then people take this they cut it and
then they put it in a package like this
so this one this one is the
microprocessor right here with a lot of
pins see the number of pins in here then
you can come and see them over here so
these are microprocessor this is a
programmable board that we use in the
lab to design this one here to design
microprocessor here as well
and this is one of our chips the one
that we build ourselves it's inside here
this little tiny black thing okay that's
one that's one of the Terminator eyes
prototype maybe the model mode model 50
would not up to the 800 that is in the
movies yeah so that's that's what I
wanted to tell you today and thank you
for coming
you